i'd love to hear your thoughts about gpt
yeah yeah
yeah in the last few months we've had
you know we've we've
the world has now seen a chat engine or
a text engine
i should say called gpt3 um
that you know i think it's still you
know it does not pass
a touring test you know there are no
real claims that it passes the touring
test
right you know this is comes out of the
group at open ai
and you know they're you know they've
been relatively careful and what they've
claimed about the system
but i think this this this
uh as clearly as eugene gooseman was not
in advance over eliza
it is equally clear that this is a major
advance over
over over eliza or really over anything
that the world has seen before
uh this is a text engine that can
come up with kind of on topic you know
reasonable sounding completions to just
about anything that you ask
you can ask it to write a poem about
topic
x in the style of poet y and it will
have a go at that
yeah and it will do you know not a perf
not a great job
not an amazing job but you know a
passable job
you know definitely you know as as good
as you know
you know in in many cases i would say
better than i would have done
right uh you know you can ask it to
write you know an
essay like a student essay about pretty
much any topic and it will get something
that i am pretty sure would get at least
a b
minus you know in most you know high
school
or even college classes right and you
know in some sense
you know the way that it did this the
way that it achieves this
um you know scott alexander of the you
know the much uh
mourned blog uh slate star codex uh had
a wonderful way of putting it he said
that
they basically just ground up the entire
internet into a slurry
okay yeah and you know and i i to tell
you the truth i had wondered for a while
why nobody had tried that
right like why not write a chat bot by
just doing deep learning over a corpus
consisting of the entire web
right and and so so so uh now they
finally have done that
right and you know the results are are
very impressive
you know it's not clear that you know
people can argue about whether this is
truly a step
toward general ai or not but this is an
amazing capability
uh that you know uh uh we didn't have
a few years ago that you know if a few
years ago
if you had told me that we would have it
now that would have surprised me
yeah and i think that anyone who denies
that is just not engaging with what's
there
so their model it takes a large part of
the internet
and compresses it in a small number of
parameters
relative to the size of the internet and
is able
to without fine tuning
uh do a basic kind of like a quarrying
mechanism
just like you describe or you specify a
kind of poet and then
you want to write a poem and somehow i
was able to do basically a look up on
the internet
well of relevant things i mean that's
what i mean i mean i mean
how else do you explain it well okay i
mean i mean the the training
involved you know massive amounts of
data from the internet and actually took
lots and lots of computer power lots of
electricity
right you know there are some some very
prosaic reasons why this wasn't done
earlier right
right but um you know it costs some tens
of millions of dollars i think you know
that's just for
approximately like a few million dollars
oh okay okay oh really okay
you know oh all right all right thank
you i mean as they as they scale it up
you know it will cost
but then the hope is cost comes down and
all that kind of stuff
but um basically you know it is a
neural net you know so i mean i mean or
what's now called a deep net but you
know they're basically the same thing
right so it's a
it's a form of you know uh algorithm
that people
have known about for decades right uh
but it is
constantly trying to solve the problem
predict the next word
right so it's just trying to uh um
predict what comes next it's not trying
to decide
what what it should say what ought to be
true
it's trying to predict what someone who
had said
all of the words up to the preceding one
would say next
although to push back on that that's how
it's trained but that's right no but
it's arguable
arguable yeah that our very cognition
could be a mechanism as that simple
source of course i never said that it
wasn't right
but right but yeah but i mean i mean
sometimes that that is you know if there
is a deep philosophical question that's
raised by gpt3 then that is it
right are we doing anything other than
you know this predictive processing just
trying to
constantly trying to fill in a blank of
what would come next after what we just
said up to this point
is that what i'm doing right now it's
impossible so
the intuition that a lot of people have
will look this thing is not going to be
able to reason
the mountain everest question do you
think it's possible that gbt56 and 7
would be able to with this exact same
process begin to
look do something that looks like
is indistinguishable to us humans from
reasoning
i mean the truth is that we don't really
know what the limits are
right because exactly because you know
what we've seen so far
is that you know gbt3 was basically the
same thing as gpt2 but just with
you know a much larger uh network
you know more training time bigger
training corpus
right and it was you know very
noticeably better
right than its immediate predecessor so
uh we you know we don't know where you
hit the ceiling here right i mean that's
the
that's the amazing part and maybe also
the scary part
right that uh you know now my guess
would be that that you know at some
point
like there has to be diminishing returns
like it can't be that simple can it
right right but i i i i wish that i had
more to base that guess on
right yeah i mean some people say that
there will be a limitation on the
we're going to hit a limit on the amount
of data that's on the internet
yes yeah yeah so sure so there's
certainly that limit
i mean there's also um you know like if
you are looking for questions that will
stump gpt three
right you can come up with some without
you know like you know even
getting it to learn how to balance
parentheses
right like it can you know it doesn't do
such a great job
right uh you know like like you know and
you know
and its failures are are ironic
right like like basic arithmetic right
and you think and you think you know
isn't that what computers are supposed
to be best at
yeah isn't that where computers already
had us beat a century ago
yeah right and yeah and yet that's where
gpt3 struggles right but it's
it's amazing you know that it's almost
like a young child in that way
right that uh uh um but
but uh somehow you know because it is
just trying to predict what what
uh comes next it doesn't know when it
should stop doing that
and start doing something very different
like some more exact logical reasoning
right and so so you know the uh uh
you know you one one is naturally led to
guess
that our brain sort of has some element
of predictive processing
but that it's coupled to other
mechanisms right that it's coupled to
you know first of all visual reasoning
which gpt-3 also doesn't have any of
right although there's some
demonstration that
there's a lot of promise there yeah it
can complete images that's right yeah
and using
exact same kind of transformer
mechanisms to like watch videos on
youtube
and uh so the same uh the same
self-supervised mechanism to be able to
look
it'd be fascinating to think what kind
of completions you could do
oh yeah no absolutely although like if
we ask it to like you know
a word problem that involve reasoning
about the locations of things in space
i don't think it does such a great job
on those right to take an example and so
so the guess would be well you know
humans have a lot of predictive
processing a lot of just filling in the
blanks but we also have these other
mechanisms that we can
couple to or that we can sort of call
the subroutines when we need to
and that maybe maybe you know to go
further that
one would want to integrate other forms
of reasoning
you